[Musique]
on
non et sa sélection de 10 cm cookies
t'arrêtes
modèle ouais
allez retourne j'ai dit non j'ai dit non
et
[Musique]
sans
fioritures not your man u
[Applaudissements]
9 de temps une view faire beaucoup mieux
et
je
devais tu fais quoi là
de bientôt tourner est là mais
le bébé il est à tomber
mais oui je vais te faire à manger le
titre roche ou bébé mais attend les ce
mot juste 15 minutes
tiens
ok
bien sûr
on
ne
non
aïe
honni de catéchèse et soyeuse
et bien voilà ça fait bien cinq minutes
que je cherche mes clés je regarde sa
tête de coupable je me couche vers lui
et voilà ce que je trouve merci raymond
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
tu peux parenté avec vous
je suis
dit tu peux pas faire ça je te connais
pas
tu peux pas partir comme on fait ça